the end is finally here and the fate of
hawkins has never been more perilous
with max in a coma the gates to the
upside down completely open and the
mystery surrounding the soviet's role in
all of it it's time to explain what went
down during the ending of season 4 of
stranger things
what started as a series of riffs
opening beneath the town expands to
include the familiar snow-like particles
of the upside down drifting into the
real world while the rifts begin to
bellow smoke and red lightning crackles
in the clouds over the city our heroes
know very well what this means even if
no one else in town does something
bigger is coming to hawkins and soon the
question that remains as the season ends
though is what exactly that bigger
something will look like we've become
very familiar with the various kinds of
creatures who exist in the upside down
over the years so is vecna simply going
to stage an all-out assault with as many
of those beasts as he can summon is he
going to bring the mind player to
colossal life over the hawkins skyline
this is what our heroes have to figure
out as they head into season 5.
mike and eleven began season four with
serious issues in their relationship for
mike a big part of the problem was not
just the physical distance from elle who
moved to california with the buyer's
family but a perceived distance in their
personalities for him elle is an
exceptional person and he's simply not
and he's sure that one day she'll
realize that and decides she doesn't
need him 4l who's been struggling with
the loss of her powers at the end of
season 3 the problem is that she
believes mike doesn't feel as strongly
about her as she feels about him she
thinks her outsider status has made her
into a kind of monster that she can
never rehabilitate by the end of the
season they both learn they're wrong
will helps convince mike that he's vital
to their entire friend group and
eleven's life as the heart of the party
and the person who keeps everyone buoyed
by hope see how you're leading us here
you're guiding the whole party inspiring
us that's what you do
through her work with dr brenner eleven
comes to realize that she's not a
monster and that she's simply been
manipulated into perceiving some kind of
wrongness in her mind and body that
leads to an emotional reunion and
reconciliation at the end of the season
but the happiness is short-lived will
they get a happy ending or are they
destined to be ripped apart again
the hawkins kid faced an unimaginable
force of darkness as season 4
transitions into season 5 but that
doesn't mean their personal lives are
completely lost in the shuffle that's
perhaps clearest in the story of robin
who reveals a crush on a fellow student
named vicki at the beginning of the
season then sees things come a bit full
circle by the end in episode 8 robin
learns that vicki has a boyfriend from
out of town but one episode later when
she finds herself volunteering beside
her crush at hawkins high school she
learns that they broke up robin and the
newly single vicki are left to bond in a
real way making sandwiches for refugees
of the earthquake and laughing and
joking together right now it's hard to
imagine what anyone's life will look
like at the end of this fight but robin
seems closer than ever to the kind of
happy ending she deserves
jonathan byers and his girlfriend nancy
wheeler are separated by geography for
much of the fourth season but there's
also something else in the way of their
relationship since moving to california
jonathan has developed doubts about his
ability to ever be enough for nancy
particularly since he won't be going to
the same college she's hoping to attend
meanwhile back in hawkins nancy is very
aware of how distant jonathan's been and
that awareness coincides with the
re-emergence of steve harrington in her
life as they battle vecna together nancy
realizes that steve has grown a lot
since they broke up it seems like a
reconciliation might be in the cards but
then jonathan returns to hawkins putting
whatever might have happened on pause we
don't know what that means for season 5
just yet but it's pretty clear that
something has to give in this love
triangle joyce byers and jim hopper
spend most of season 4 trying to get
back to each other this is triggered
when joyce receives a message from
hopper that reveals he's being held in a
soviet prison joyce finally finds her
way to the prison only to find that
hopper's life is in a fresh kind of
danger it's only at the very end of the
season as they're working to find a way
to get back to america that the two can
come together as a proper couple once
again the happy reunion doesn't hold out
for long hopper and joyce make it back
to the states and time to find that the
kids fight against the upside down has
gone very wrong hawkins is now engulfed
in a full-on disaster as rifts open up
across the town the big question as we
head into season 5 is just how hopper
and joyce will make it through this
fight intact they lost each other once
already now they have to fight to make
sure it doesn't happen again
all of the hawkins kids are going
through their own major struggles in
stranger things four but will byers is
going through one of the hardest rough
patches of his young life in part
because he's doing much of it struggling
alone it's been speculated ever since a
key moment in season 3 that will is gay
l is not stupid it's not my fault you
don't like girls
fans think that eventually he'll come
out to his friends and perhaps even
reveal that he's in love with his best
friend mike wheeler in season 4 we get
more than one moment in which will seems
to allude to his secret in one very
potent moment near the end of the season
it seems like he's almost going to say
it but he keeps silent out of concern
for the larger fight will's personal
narrative remains stalled but it's clear
that he's aching to tell someone
something about the secret he's keeping
then there's will's other inner turmoil
something that hasn't been addressed
directly since season two will still has
at least some connection to the upside
down thanks to his possession by the
mind player once wekna launches his
invasion will's been feeling it more and
more will he be able to hold himself
together in the fight to come or is he
destined for an inner battle that's just
as dangerous as the external one near
the end of stranger things four eleven
makes a devastating discovery about her
puff-puff dr martin brenner she realizes
as brenner pushes her to stay in his
secret lab and cultivate her powers even
further that the experiments she
remembers from hawkins lab were never
about her they were always about using
her to get closer to henry he was
brenner's first patient who 11 cent to
the upside down in that hellish place he
transformed into the creature the kids
call vecta sometimes
papa doesn't tell the truth
it's a major moment of catharsis for 11
who realizes that the problem was never
her and her powers but it's also an
interesting wrinkle in the ongoing saga
of what was going on at hawkins lab it's
clear in season 4 that there are still
plenty of dark forces within the us
government who are squabbling over the
nature of the lab the upside down and 11
herself what's less clear is whether or
not anyone else knew about what brenner
was really trying to achieve if someone
did know are they out there trying to
finish his work does anyone else know
what henry has become these are the
questions that could have major
implications for what's coming in the
final season about halfway through
season four dr martin brenner and dr sam
owens form an uneasy alliance with the
shared goal of getting eleven's powers
back to full strength through the use of
the neenah machine by the end of the
season they're at odds again as owens
tries to let eleven leave to help her
friends and brenner is determined to
keep her in the lab longer to try and
reach one in the upside down then the
entire operation is disrupted when
lieutenant colonel sullivan and his
troops arrive killing brenner capturing
owens and trying to end the operation
once and for all by killing 11. by the
end of the season 11 is a fugitive from
the evil forces in the human world
pursuing her who wants her not just
contained but dead this explains why
she's going back into hiding in hopper's
cabin at the end of the season but what
we still don't know is just how far the
government will go to capture her
especially now that rifts have opened
all over hawkins it's a conflict that's
arguably just as important to her
survival as the fight against the upside
down
the end of stranger things 4 reveals
many things and not all of them come
from the united states during the
process of escaping from hopper's soviet
prison hopper and joyce discover a
secret lab full of preserved demogorgons
and demidogs as well as a chamber full
of swirling particles the soviets dubbed
the shadow this strange entity is later
revealed to be the dark material that
makes up the mind flare by the end of
the season the facility is basically
destroyed but its presence and brenner's
insistence that his experiments were all
about fighting the soviets raises some
interesting questions the soviet
government has its own operation tied to
the upside down perhaps geared towards
the weaponization of its creatures for a
fight against the west what remains to
be seen now is how that fight will
progress now that the prison facility is
destroyed
in an effort to defeat vekna before he
can invade hawkins max mayfield stages a
daring self-sacrificing trap for the
creature using her previous connection
to him to lure him out after some
coaxing the plan works but what doesn't
work quite as well were the parts of the
plan surrounding max's effort she's able
to lure vechna in and hide in a happy
memory for a while but the upside down's
pressure on her friends means that the
plot to kill vecta is delayed and max is
caught in the same psychic force that
killed three other hawkins teenagers by
the end of the battle vecna is driven
away but max is dead revived only by the
force of eleven's powers at the end of
the season max is in a coma in a
hospital bed her limbs broke and her
sight apparently gone and worse her
consciousness seemingly unreachable
eleven tries to go into her mind and
find her to search for some sign that
max is still in there somewhere and
isn't able to locate her so where is max
it's a big potentially devastating
question for season 5.
the final two episodes of stranger
things 4 reveal several new elements of
the show's backstory including how
vechna began to shape the upside down to
his will
i want you to tell her
everything you see
revealed through the discussion of his
backstory that once he was sent to the
upside down by eleven's powers he
wandered the landscape until he found
the shadow from there he sculpted it
into the mind flair making him the real
power behind the entire invasion of
hawkins even with that reveal there's a
good deal we still don't know about the
upside down it seems that many of the
dimensions creatures including
demigorgons were already inhabitants
when vechna got there now they're all
part of an extended hive mind of which
he is the master with the shadow
retaining a sort of symbiotic connection
to his will so what is the shadow why
does it work for vecna and what does
that mean for the larger fight there's
still so much we don't know about the
nature of this other dimension and that
feels like one of the biggest open
questions going into season 5.
at the end of part 1 of stranger things
4 nancy wheeler makes a shocking
discovery about the upside down or at
least about the version of hawkins that
exists within the upside down the entire
landscape is frozen in time a version of
hawkins as it existed in 1983 when
eleven first opened the gate in the lab
and released the first demogorgon it
seems that somehow at that moment a
duplicate version of hawkins emerged in
the upside-down landscape only to remain
frozen in time
we're in the past
at the moment it's not clear what that
means it's possible that 11's powers
accidentally created a weird mirror
image of hawkins lab and the surrounding
town at the moment she opened the gate
it could have something to do with
fekna's invasion plans whatever's going
on it's clear that the mirror image of
hawkins in the upside down will remain
an intriguing centerpiece of the
conflict going forward into season five
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you